hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in book 1 of on the ends Cicero has
torquatus as the representative of the
epicurean position in ethics defend the
Epicureans against both what other
philosophers particularly the Stoics but
also what you might say ordinary people
unaffected by philosophy might make of
the epicurean position and indeed when
we hear this word epicurean today we
often picture to ourself somebody who is
particularly obsessed with food and
drink and enjoying those to the greatest
extent somebody who's you know a wine
snob or a foodie and just eating eating
eating drinking drinking drinking and
there was in fact this popular
perception of the Epicureans going all
the way back to the time of Epicurus of
course if you know some Epicureans in
the genuine philosophical sense you
realize that this is a caricature and
and it's rather unrepresentative of them
to think that they particularly indulge
in all of these bodily pleasures you
know wallowing around like pigs in the
mud just you know enjoying the
proverbial wine women song or whatever
else you want to bring in so why do
people have this perception of the
Epicureans why do they say it's a life
rather unworthy of the human being
Epicurus himself had an answer to this
and torquatus is going to give us a
rather short version of this and it has
to do with a distinction between two
fundamentally different kinds of
pleasures so when we think about
pleasant things drinking coffee for
example enjoying the taste of the coffee
and in my case adding a little bit of
milk to provide some fat and some sugars
to it as well that would
an example of a moving or kinetic
pleasure as Epicurus called it and
Cicero will use these terms later on in
book 2 to describe this torquatus is not
himself using it but these sorts of
pleasures they satisfies some sort of
desire that we have and we come to you
know have more and more desires the more
that we have these pleasures and they
give some sort of enjoyment to the
senses and it's a little bit difficult
to describe this in ways that are very
analytic but it's you know a decent way
of talking about it
he says the pleasure we pursue is not
that kind of loan which directly affects
our physical being are not Torah in the
Latin with a delightful feeling a swot
you know certainly the term here is
swabbies hot eh
right and then he talks about it as
providing some sort of enjoyment or
delightful feeling for the senses and
that is you couldn't eat at a in this so
it's something that you can relate to
you know think about all the physical
pleasures that you enjoy and what it is
that it's like to experience them that's
one kind of pleasure but and here's a
key insight of Epicurus some of the
pleasures that we feel they're not so
much about having somebody stroking our
skin or drinking some wine or something
along those lines it's rather the
absence the removal the prevention of
something bad so it's not just that
there's a positive side positive
pleasure and a negative side pain the
negative of a negative in this
is also a positive but it's a positive
of a different sort than the other kind
of positive so these are what the
Epicureans called static pleasures and
these you might think of as pleasures of
rest pleasures of freedom pleasures of
removal of pain or to use two other
terms that come up of fear because at
the curious and torquatus following him
said that every fear ultimately stems
from some sort of pain and if you think
about what it's like to feel fear or
anxiety it's not painful in the same way
that poking yourself in the eye is but
it is a troubling feeling likewise
distress or sorrow by a guru to do' in
the latin that also stems from pain or
could be included within it if you like
and we might think of all sorts of other
feelings that are also painful anger
isn't mentioned here but it would be a
prime example or desire for that which
you cannot enjoy a kind of despair of
ever attaining what it is that you truly
want like being in love and knowing that
you will never enjoy the affection of
the one you're in love with that would
be something as well and if you can
remove these things whether they're
fears about the gods or fears about
what's going to happen to you down the
line when you die or before you die or
what's going to happen to your property
after you die or whether it's sadness is
what whatever sort of effective state it
is the removal of that Cicero
tells us the Epicureans thought is in
fact a great pleasure and the Epicureans
thought that that was an even greater
pleasure
he says when we are released
from pain the mere sensation of complete
emancipation and relief from this
uneasiness is itself a source of
gratification but everything that causes
gratification is a pleasure here we have
a different mode of pleasure than the
other types of pleasure that are in some
respect a little bit more direct and
notice that these static pleasures could
also be longer-lasting than other
pleasures if you drink your coffee you
can only drink so much coffee or beer or
whatever else it is you can only stuff
your face full of so much food
Aristotle actually talks about a glutton
who wish that his neck was as long as
Historics they could feel that physical
sensation of feeling oneself up going
down the throat even if you had a long
neck you can only eat so much but these
static pleasures we can enjoy them for a
very long time feeling a sense of
security security is a lack of fear a
lack of a certain sort of pain these the
Epicureans held were much better so uses
example you know the complete removal of
pain like hunger and thirst when you
banish them by food and drink the mere
fact of getting rid of uneasiness brings
a resultant pleasure and it's trained
there's the pleasure of eating which is
a moving pleasure and then there's the
pleasure of not being bothered by thirst
or hunger or we could think of so many
other physical sensations as well being
able to rest and recline and perhaps go
to sleep could be a static pleasure the
feeling of relaxation that comes after
exercise could be another static
pleasure and we could go on and on and
on even the enjoyment that we take in
not having anything to do not having
anything on the list having a open week
and here he can just take it easy could
be a static pleasure
so the torquatus goes on and he says
generally the removal of pain causes
pleasure to take its place
so Epicurus as opposed to other people
said there is no middle ground between
pleasure and pain in the sense of
something neutral in the sense of
something that would have no positive or
negative value instead he said the this
entire absence of pain is a pleasure and
a pleasure of the highest order he says
some Ville up Takuma the greatest
pleasure so he says a man who is
conscious of his condition at all must
necessarily feel either pleasure or pain
but this complete absence of pain
Epicurus says is the limit and the
highest point of pleasure beyond this
point pleasure may vary to some degree
in kind you can have different kinds of
pleasures right but it won't vary in
intensity and degree so really the
epicurean life is going to be more
oriented by this greater pleasure that
comes from removals of pains and all the
other sorts of things that fall under
the rubric of pain like being worried
about what's going to happen when you
die or whether the gods are going to
strike you down or any of those sorts of
things he also tells us an interesting
thought experiment he sets this out for
us that shows that we do in fact require
both kinds of pleasures if we want to
have the best life as epicurean so he
suggests that you you think about a
person living in the continuous
enjoyment of numerous and vivid
pleasures of body and of mind
undisturbed so here's the important part
about you know static pleasures
undisturbed by the presence or the
prosper
of pain so there's no pain right there
and there's no pain likely to come in
the future
what possible state of existence could
we describe as being more excellent or
more desirable he says a person in this
case must possess in the first place of
strength of mind that is proof against
all fear of death or pain he will know
death means complete unconsciousness
pain is generally light if long short if
strong so that its intensity is
compensated by brief duration it's
continuous by diminishing severity this
man will have no worries about any
supernatural power he will never suffer
the pleasures of the past to fade away
but will remember them and won't feel
regret about them and his lot will be
one which will not admit of further
improvement for the Epicureans this is
what the best life would look like it
would include both types of pleasures
but a lot of that would stem from the
complete removal of any pains or fears
he goes on with the thought experiment
to say let's imagine another person who
he says is crushed beneath the heaviest
load of mental and bodily anguish grant
him no hope of immediate relief in view
give him no pleasure either present or
in prospect can you imagine a more
pitiable state if a life full of pain is
the thing the most to be avoided then
the life that is free of that pain would
be the best and so this is how torquatus
portrays the epicurean position quite
faithfully as we can tell and the real
stress is going to lie on these
pleasures that are really about removing
or preventing pain so this is a reply to
anyone who would say oh you Epicureans
are just pleasure seekers you're always
pursuing pleasures the Epicureans could
say no we stop pursuing
we free ourselves and then we enjoy the
higher pleasures
you